the rage oh this big offense what does
so much damage huge so huge organ hall
[Applause]
and they torch so touchdown
[Music]
[Music]
so they're gonna give me a cigar meeting
without a good moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
it
[Music]
that is uh
[Music]
Wow family Amazon let them go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god teachers
[Music]
oh here we go
see we're all on board for a platoons it
out
I like the harassed in here uses and
lows
oh that idea that is it down on kuku
Don's of course getting third the legend
if you're watching Harve it up from
Yoko that's all
oh well you got no hops again today
Yogi's oh well
[Music]
but looks like he's gonna have to start
taking risk here against to none oh my
god that could have been able dropped
out MIT that is definitely is the hell
sweep is going to seal the deal
futons goes into those grand finals
we're on trying to get this back passing
I like to be in Das Boot
look at the look on James chance here a
4/4 nice clock running to to try to get
out of that corner no punishment futon I
like the delay there with all four form
but still not landing it babies are way
too sharp and that might be in that's
the reset and we're going into another
sad ladies and gentlemen baby CR he's
like I don't care who you would thank
you wow that push back so far another
slide but the sidestep to JDC are taking
thanks for tuning in oh and of course
you know the team at switch is working
around the [ __ ] so many events begin so
make sure you guys check out second
world tour
bloody Shanghai punished from JD CRT
steel fancy up for for gonna get a small
combo that was gonna be big again the
advantage still at JDC arts paper
whittling away of what the dog has left
of life
nice punish it with one thing before you
get some back down Oh big wah wah stay
tuned that was on the wrist as well
oh that's not it that is definitely not
it that's not it
that's it oh my god kunos moves on once
again yo God have a chance
oh yeah what's he gonna do with it
though is he in a slide what's gonna do
get somebody on it arroba able to hold
it down we're gonna find out right now
maybe history
one tiny recipe oh my gosh this doubt
this night and this is gonna hurt big
size
oh he missed a little anything could
happen
anything could happen right now David
feel anything could happen
bouton boobs are the living HDR was able
to defeat the dogs last week but we got
slowly back to week is over learning
relearning the matchup able to prove
that he was able to be the victor do it
three times
[Music]
to happen lock the traitors gonna have
like oh no because they've got a recent
three Oh
back to one cool I feel alive
I need wait oh he's in right now oh and
that can be going to a final man one
more man ladies and gentlemen qu9 nice
topple their perky dogs made another
hail sweet the llama is father wolf
right now he needs to keep something
Thunder Gossage gets the follow up
what's gonna happen Lord for the damage
here out for the bid of four four
Oh Saturday loved one to two down back
to anything is gonna do it right now
we're Lancer with the down whoa oh my
god the final it 15 seconds left that
glued on sexy ladies and gentlemen he
takes out each age of makers crouton
secures himself a spot in the taking
world tour finals
man what a sin make some noise ladies
and gentlemen what a sick all right
looking at will he have on the winners
side we have JD CR and food on tissue
Mon and saying this is quite a run back
because both these players have been
denied today and as I was mentioning
earlier food and
one day what they would
er which no one has been able to open
put this be another two names miracle
maybe you never know you got the chance
here
oh he let him you let him tell you what
for though key not over yet one flash
punch the whipping Wow Oh get it work
Ranger oh it did not fall for it this
time
JC our office world war is dirty that
first match
he filled in and their account another
best electric razor scraper Niels the
deal despite all those mistakes Thank
You Don and why have you think about it
he didn't land electricity diddle NLCC
those one with strata pooping input turn
stealing oh man he's gonna extend it's
eating it the whole day yeah he gets it
two part that's a big chunk all he went
for the play oh they're just going for
the mids now all the side steps here oh
that's not what you want to get jump
this is an outrage
[Applause]
puts me right at our my eye I feel like
this was your reaction last night we did
Oh
who does this moving on sore winner
finals
give it up the garden Oh get the follow
and just like that
- dad's going to losers bracket yeah and
see maybe it was a you know maybe you
just stand tall and like Ryan
Oh God Danny oh my gosh
hey remember me I'm that same guy three
times in a row
don't forget it my god I'll never forget
it don't forget the Miller
oh my god Bobby ah let me tell you gotta
be kidding me
the wall oh wow oh my gums counterman
free him tapping him on the way in the
time what's he gonna do the autopilot on
with it there's no time left and that
that is gonna do it
oh what a way
for tech videos we are going to our
first batch this is the grand finals
going upstairs
one more fixin to do it he's right by
the wall
when she's not that he could have killed
oh it's out of range
oh my god babylegs check that combo
check this
where's my water
oh man
the breaks like that off for the whole
Epcot visit again good boy
and on
oh the reset and it looks like st. just
smelled a fart right there he did not
like the smell of that would be a big
factor oh and that is always a comment
back to here with the machine was
persued that we're gonna need such a
miracle oh my god he got him it's not
much more of a miracle laughs oh no I
don't think either button at all
[Applause]
oh yeah I mean he got so many miracle
comebacks it's it's like you can all -
what up legend oh my god did you see
that
we are witnessing something amazing
right here to see below there's no time
Oh
[Music]
my god
[Music]
gosh
[Music]
big not this electricity very
Oh
not so much damage
ha
Oh
[Applause]
to the gun
[Music]
second seven
máximo
do a final check
this man has come a long way this man is
there you go that's your tech a world
tour champion that's your ticket World
Tour champion
[Music]